okay hi everybody thanks for joining us
today in the genetics and genomics
session my name is Kevin Holden I am the
head of science at cyndago and I'm going
to be talking to you today about the
development of an arrayed whole human
genome gene knockout library using an
optimized multi sgrna CRISPR approach
and just kind of for the the agenda
today I'm going to tell you a little bit
about what the company that I work as a
scientist for cyntha code does and also
how we've optimized CRISPR approaches
for generating gene knockouts like are
used in the library I'm going to tell
you about today and then how we've
actually gone around designing and
building this arrayed whole human genome
knockout library and then lastly how you
may be able to use this library as a
powerful resource in your own research
applications
just kind of so we're all on the same
page going to be talking a lot about you
slicing the crisper Cassadine technology
to engineer G milk outs and how they can
actually accelerate to your own research
and development and so kind of the old
way that that people used to do gene
knockouts if they're trying to attain a
gene knockout was to use a technology
called
si RNA or the silencing RNA and while
this was quite effective for some people
it really was not a complete gene
knockout it's more of a gene knockdown
it's very transient in nature so you're
actually not making a permanent genetic
change
you're just making kind of a transient
gene knockdown and one of the real big
drawbacks of this technology is that you
tended to see kind of these off-target
effects where essentially these short
RNA molecules could affect the activity
translation of other genes that were
protect perhaps unintended targets so it
really did kind of make generating gene
knockouts not the most effective way and
so there really are some good reasons
why you may want to knock a gene out in
Euro research
these can include trying to discover the
the function of a protein it can also be
to validate an antibody that you
developed against a particular gene or
for validating an assay that you're
working in and then also it could be
that you're trying to analyze a
particular pathway in a Cell and one way
to perturb different nodes in that
pathway in order to understand it better
is to actually knock out the genes and
the associated proteins that are a
components of that pathway
and something else we'll talk about
today is using gene knockouts in this
library format for doing functional
genomic screening so this could it could
be that you're working on drug discovery
you're trying to identify a new
therapeutic target or validate a
therapeutic target it could be that
you're interested in repurposing a drug
or small molecule so screening an
already a compounds already known to be
active it's a way to see if it can
affect other proteins inside of a cell
or for understanding concepts such as
synthetic lethality and understand how
you can initiate for example apoptosis
in a Cell and so just so we're all on
the same page just to kind of back out a
little bit we're going to be talking
about the CRISPR caste 9 technology for
generating gene knockouts it's a very
powerful molecular biology tool
essentially it's utilizing a strand of
RNA that is used to program and
nucleates in this particular case the
castle and nucleus it programs that
nucleus to a specific location on a
genome and then initiates a
double-stranded break and powerful tool
because once you initiate this
double-stranded break genomes have to
repair themselves so in order for cells
to stay alive and they can do that in
one of two ways on the left we can see
the non-homologous end joining or nhej a
repair pathway this is when you make a
double-stranded break in the genome and
essentially the solver repairs itself
using a lot of this double-stranded
break protein love these double-stranded
break protein repair pathways and these
can end up forming what's called an
insertion or deletion or an in del and
typically if these in dolls form in a
region that's coding for a particular
protein then these can lead to a
frameshift which can lead to a gene
knockout and we're going to mostly talk
about that today
also this technology as you may know can
be used to do what's called homology
directed repair where you supply a donor
DNA fragment typically a single stranded
piece of DNA as a template in order for
you to generate specific single new
we tied variants or specific knock ins
and program really specific changes into
the genome
and so there are many different
applications for this technology in both
disease research and therapeutics we can
see here that you can utilize these
reagents so the the Cassadine nucleus my
guide RNA and you can directly inject
those into an embryo of an organism to
build a bottle so for a mouse or for a
zebrafish or fruit fly and you can also
put them directly into cell it could be
a primary cell like a t-cell or it could
be a stem cell maybe you want to develop
an organ ID and then they can also be
used to generate in vitro models of
disease in for example cell lines but
they can also be used to do high
throughput screening we're going to talk
about that mostly today and then there's
really the big promise of CRISPR from
the therapeutic side so maybe if you
identify a target through
high-throughput screening that you're
interested in developing a gene therapy
for these can be you these components
can be used to do in vivo gene editing
so directly affecting a genetically
diseased organ in a person or these
reagents can be used to edit self come
from a patient are edited in vitro and
an ex vivo transplanted back into the
patient so perhaps the primary t-cell or
or a stem cell of some kind
just to kind of also give you an
overview of what sent ago as the company
does and I'll talk a little bit about
why and how we developed the this
library and the approach that we've
taken really is to provide the goal of a
company is really to provide access to
genome engineering tools and so kind of
the first thing we did in order to do
that was we developed a new synthesis
architecture for making the RNA molecule
components so the long single guided
single guide RNA molecules and really we
were the first company to make a factory
that could mass-produce these and
they're chemically modified and hundred
nucleotides in length and so really in
order to generate libraries you really
need to have the capabilities to
synthesize a large amounts of this
material so why do we chemically modify
these single guides well this is really
a landmark paper that came from the lab
of Matthew Porteous of Stanford
University showing that if you
chemically modify these single guide
RNAs and you you use them in this duplex
with castle and nucleus you could very
you could essentially edit very
effectively these primary human cells
like TESOL or stem cells and they showed
that you could really go from just doing
you know forming these in dealt and a
lower percentage you know two to five
percent of the cells and your population
all the way up to 80 to 90 percent so it
really was kind of a landmark paper in
the CRISPR cast nine field and so what
we've done as a company is we took that
approach and we figured out a way to
mass-produce and synthesize these RNA
molecules so we in 2016 we launched a
factory that could make these things
using a novel synthesis architecture
that's controlled entirely by software
and this Factory actually is capable of
synthesizing over a million-and-a-half
guide RNAs per year either in you know
tubes or actually in these library
plates as well which I'll talk about
today we can make it all the way up to
Graham scale as well so we were actually
focusing on building a GMP pipeline so
we can can we can essentially support
researchers from Discovery all the way
from the bench into the clinic and if
you
curious to know what this factory we've
regenerated looks like there's a new
documentary film that premiered at South
by Southwest this year 2019 produced by
dan Rather and Adam bolt actually talks
a lot about the crisper cast mind
technology and the the cyntha code
factory is featured in this film you can
see in the window in the top right there
along with your favorite CRISPR friends
Jennifer Doudna George church funds Aang
so if you're interested please check out
human nature film comm you can you can
see what the simply go RNA Factory is
all about so enough of the movie plugs
going back to the science really we work
with mostly with this rmp complex format
so it stands for ribonucleoproteins
where you have a purified cast 9 nucleus
you've duplex did it with these
chemically modified synthetic single
guide RNAs and this really was kind of
state-of-the-art going back about three
years to 2016 now and so really is the
most effective way to deliver CRISPR
into a cell I'll also be talking today
about how other methods that you can
deliver the RNA directly into your cells
for screening for example but using
these are MPs they're much easier to
transect into cell from plasmids they're
transient so you don't get these off
target rates that you can get with
constitutive expression of the CRISPR
components in the plasmid you get very
high editing rates and it's very common
to be able to form in Delvin your genes
up to the 90% range and you can knock in
a single nucleotide variants quite
effectively as well and really a
powerful advantage of using this format
is that you don't need to use any
antibiotics or selection in your screens
or your editing in general we can see
that when we use these are mts in
numerous cell types using methods like
nucleus section so electroporation that
you really can effectively form in Dells
in the large a wide range of different
cell types ranging from cancer cell
lines to suspension cell if primary
human t-cell IPS lines or animal cells
and again we mostly a focus on
synthesizing these single long guide
RNAs the
100 nucleotide approach we we have
looked at the older two-part systems but
you can appreciate from this graph here
that we've been able to obtain some of
these two-part systems from from other
vendors and when we compare them we just
really see that the single guys are much
more active across a wide range of
different targets this screen was done
in heck 2 9 3 cells but essentially as a
provider of genome engineering tools and
we're trying to provide the best access
the customers we focused on the single
guide format because as you can see and
we found in our own research and you can
find yourself these really are the most
effective way to engineer cells using
CRISPR cassadine
here we're looking at a 384-well plate
electroporation plate nuclear section
when we've taken the same guide RNA
we've consistently nucleic fitted into
384 different pools of cell and you can
see that they're remarkably consistent
and this is great because it tells us
that the the process we use for making
this material is very consistent as well
so you can start to get very
reproducible experiments this is really
important if you're doing the screen you
want to make sure the material you're
using in your library in the screen is
very high quality and it's not going to
have a lot of variation between
experimental replicas and so just kind
of back up and talk a little bit about
what we've done we've developed this
consistent synthesis method for making
these RNA molecules but as you'll see
later used in this library that we
developed it gives you very reproducible
results and it turns out it's very
applicable too because you get a lot of
reproducibility for automation and doing
CRISPR scale and generating large
datasets like a like a screen and in the
course of doing this we've had to
develop some bio frenetic tools that can
help design and also analyze our CRISPR
experiments know talked a little bit
about those before you move onto the
library the first is the ascent ago ice
tool so it stands for inference of
crisper edits this is a tool that it's
we developed internally for our own use
but it's also free for any researcher to
use online there's an online portal for
this and so we have a submission in the
bar archive we can read all about the
algorithms we developed in order to
build this tool but essentially it's a
way of analyzing CRISPR editing using
PCR of of the region you're trying to
edit in yourselves or your cell pool and
then getting Sanger sequencing data back
which you can literally get back the
next day and then doing a very quick
analysis of that population of cells to
determine the editing frequency and in
the archive submission you can see the
very good correlation with with more
time-consuming and expensive methods
like next-generation sequencing so this
is really good a really good proxy for
understanding exactly what's happening
in yourselves with your CRISPR added
we made this tool so we could do
high-throughput editing analysis so in
this particular example we're looking at
500 different samples that we've done
CRISPR cast line editing in individual
Wells and so you can batch upload large
data sets using this tool which is
really great for doing large-scale
genomic analysis which is something you
may do in a screen in order to check the
quality of the screen so you can just
drag these files in a zip file into this
web interface again it's free to use
it's very useful and the outputs you can
see is you get these very nice
visualization that can actually
demonstrate the the contribution of
specific genotypes in the pool of cells
and they give you back a nice core which
stands for the amount of CRISPR editing
you're seeing and also a knockout score
which is the percentage of those in
those that can actually generate a
frameshift so this typically means that
they're indulged or non divisible by by
3 so they can actually generate a
nonsense frameshift
in your in your coding region this tool
also has knockin analysis which is very
useful for other applications but
essentially doing crisp and high
throughput is allowed us to build better
on target models for understanding how
we can predict crisper activity and here
we're just looking at several different
models that predict crisper activity and
then comparing them to what we actually
observed when we use the RMP approach
you can see that the correlations are
quite poor so essentially this means
that many of the guide RNAs
that are recommended using these
different design tools if you will
really are kind of under predicting the
activity the true activity of these
guide RNAs and so you know as a company
we thought
can we actually predict these ourselves
this is data we first presented the Cold
Spring Harbor CRISPR cast line
conference last year in 2018 the show
that we can actually predict the
distribution of the indulgent form based
on the sequence of the guy that you're
using in the localized region and so
this is very powerful because we can
actually predict in Dells before we
actually do the experiment so this
allows us to control and understand
better
what were the RNA that we're
synthesizing and if it's going to be
effective in in generating a G milk out
so doing this in silico prediction was
very useful to us and because we
developed these tools for analyzing
CRISPR and high throughput for we can
get very effective CRISPR editing we
started to think of the company and we
actually automate this part of the
CRISPR workflow to build these in vitro
models for for generating high
throughput and it's also thought is
thinking like if we're going to generate
these in vitro models of disease and
we're going to knock genes out what's
really the best way of doing that and so
again we really wanted to try to enable
access of standardization of the
technology to to many scientists and so
we kind of thought hey let's build a
platform where we can automate CRISPR
cell engineering in high-throughput and
if you want to do that it turns out it's
actually quite difficult because you
have to take into consideration all of
these different factors if you're if
you're trying to build an automated
system for doing CRISPR editing and how
you design your experiment and set them
up how you actually do the transaction
optimize that transaction and how you
manipulate cells edit them and isolate
your clones this is true whether you're
doing cell line generation or
high-throughput screening and really
this is kind of an overview all the
things we do at sim to go in a software
driven process to to do gene editing in
ourselves but it breaks down into kind
of these five categories designing
material like I mentioned optimizing
transfection and then doing editing
analysis and and clonal expansion of
salt if you're working in a library
that's not so important so we developed
a solution for automating cell lines in
high-throughput and we started to think
about what's the best way that we can
optimize protocols and methods for for
maximizing gene knockouts in gene knock
G knockin
so if you want to build a CRISPR
high-throughput platform it really you
want to start by doing the easiest
things first like a gene knockout and
then focusing on the hard things like a
knockin later so we really wanted to try
to understand how we could optimize
editing in virtually any cell line and
this will help us not only figure out
how to do CRISPR editing and
high-throughput for cell and generation
but also for doing CRISPR screenings in
any cell line that's every time we bring
a new cell line into that sense ago we
run it through an optimization a
protocol where we essentially test over
200 conditions and it's in a very few
days we can really move up the optimal
editing efficiency from protocols that
are often given by different research
groups or companies that make the rate
of the electroporation device for
example and we can push this up into
into regions that makes it very
practical worthwhile doing so in this
case we move from 77% to a 72% that's
great because now you don't have to do
so you can really rely that what you're
generating in your screen or your cell
line actually has the Edit that you want
as we've done this from multiple
different cell lines than we've done all
of these types of optimizations but
welcome back to what I was saying really
we wanted to try to figure out if we're
going to do crisper and high throughput
what's really the best way that we can
kind of guarantee that we're always
going to get a knock out of a gene so
we're going to we're going to start to
do gene knockout projects we maybe want
to go into doing some functional
screening on our own so how can we
really guarantee that you can always
knock a gene out what's the best way of
doing this and so again I'm mostly going
to be talking about the data I show you
today is mostly focused on using our MPs
the RMP approach and nucleus acting them
and then a little bit later I'll talk
about how we there are some other
methods you can use to to get the crisp
reagents into different types of cells
or cell lines it's really kind of the
old way of trying to knock a gene out in
the early days is you would use one of
those scoring algorithms like I showed
you earlier that maybe don't predict so
well and you would actually go through
and you'd pick three or four different
guide RNAs and find the PEM sequences
and then do some sort of analysis in
this particular case we're looking at
ice analysis so this is Sanger
sequencing analysis in order to
determine which one is forming in which
guide is forming in Dells at the highest
rate so on the Left we can see we've
done some editing and these in this Mel
C 2 C 12 cell line of the my OD 1 gene
in the middle where
done some editing in this PGP one IPSC
line and unload rights we're trying to
edit these primary humans he solves and
you can see there's really kind of a
wide range of different genotypes if you
will that are outcomes of picking
different guide RNAs in different
regions so again we're trying to knock a
genome so we're targeting an early exon
in a primary transcript of a gene in
order to generate these indices melon or
Mulligan and joining in dole Sween we
can make a frameshift and then get a
subsequent protein knockout so this
seemed like a good approach but there
really are some drawbacks doing this and
the first being that you often have to
screen several guide RNAs to find the
best one that works
so we developed a tool previously like I
mentioned to kind of predict this
activity and it's pretty good at doing
that but not perfect sometimes you can
get guide RNAs actually don't perform
very well in these early exons so if
that happens you're just not going to
get a very strong knockout phenotype
because you just can't form in dolls in
high enough percentages in those early
early exons and then also very important
is that not all in Dells can actually
cause frame shifts and below is some ice
analysis where we can see that there are
some genotypes in the silver we looked
at the form these minus 3 or minus 6 in
dolls and they're essentially because
there are derivatives of 3 which is the
same as like a codon there essentially
probably not going to cause a frame
shift leading to a protein knock on
that's a problem so we started thinking
like could we actually we a hypothesis
we actually mix some of these guide RNAs
together and see if they can work
together and so what we would do is we
go through we at the beginning we'd pick
several of these top-scoring guide RNAs
based on algorithms like the densha
algorithm I showed you earlier in that
in a chart and try to generate a
fragment deletion that you could use to
cause a frameshift and so we kind of
considered just kind of pooling all of
these guide RNAs together maybe picking
the top four or five scoring guide RNAs
in a particular region of a gene and
seeing if they work together there are
some technical issues with this the
first being that before we developed the
the ice tool for analysis the existing
Sanger sequencing analysis of tools like
the tide tool really can handle some of
these deletions that we were generating
by you mixing the guides together and
getting kind of multiple crisper cuts in
the same region so before this came out
we were really kind of just recommending
that people use single guides to knock
genes out but what we could see when we
mix these together and here we're
actually looking at the analysis from
using the ice tool that we developed and
also the the tide tool which is kind of
the the legacy tool for a Sanger
sequencing analysis we could see that
when we added two or three of these
guide RNAs together and here we're
editing in a heck 293 line we could kind
of get this combinatorial effect we can
actually only see using the high stool
that's because we were mixing these guys
together and they were generating these
larger fragment deletions maybe 50 base
pairs or greater in this early exon of a
gene and so if you caused this fragment
deletion in an early exon it's it's
definitely going to cause a gene
knockout so it's it's going to be a
problem and you won't but whatever you
transcribe after that is essentially
going to be nonsense
and then but again the ice tool was only
able to identify the larger fragments
than the type the title could but we saw
that you know adding two or three guides
again we really Inc were able to
dramatically increase on the activity
and kind of the knock out compared to
using a single guide and so that like I
mentioned that fragment deletion
genotype seem to be really favored
strongly and again it leads to a strong
knock out corresponding knock out
phenotype so we tried this again with
several of the cell lines and different
locations in different genes and we can
see that when we actually use three
guide RNAs over two we could get more of
a consistent result so more of a
consistent high rate of editing so more
of a consistent pattern of this of this
fragment deletion and so we looked at
some larger data sets and here we can
see on the left the individual guide
RNAs and on the right we've kind of
multiplex these together and you can see
there's a bit of an increase here from
about you know 65% a little bit over 70%
of the total indulge that you're seeing
in this population and that's great so
we're getting a bit of a bump here but
several things to consider that are
important is one is that these are
actually just indulge we're looking at
here and so they may not even call frame
shifts and the other thing was we
weren't completely sure if using the
spacing that we were using this small
region maybe 50 base pairs or so what's
this and what's good enough and what's
important and literally we couldn't
analyze anything bigger than that
so we went back to the software
development team and we're able to
develop a tool an add-on for the ice
tool that allowed us to actually accept
three different guide RNAs in a region
of about one KB and so this allowed us
to deconvolute these more complex
genotypes from these larger fragment
deletions so we decided to generate a
larger data set from a larger experiment
when we took over about a hundred genes
with 500 unique guide or single guide
RNAs in them represented maybe about
1,700 predicted different editing
outcomes and so what we're looking at
here is actually the end and spacing and
how far apart we space these guide RNAs
and as you can see we kind of
bio stem cells in this experiment
because we were considering that the the
guide RNAs that are closer together
would actually work more effectively in
a cooperative manner if they were close
together and so the negative numbers
here actually means guide RNAs that are
overlapping we thought this would be the
most effective way of doing this and so
when we first did the first screen we
looked at the first set of guide RNAs
that went out to about 80 bases 80 base
pairs and spacing we could see that
there was kind of this wide range of
activity of an efficiency of indoles
that we were forming but interestingly
there was this kind of sub population on
the right here where we had guides that
were very there were spaced very far
apart and we could see that we were
always getting high levels of editing
efficiency when we spaced these guys
really far apart so we decided to look
at the rest of the guys that were really
far apart and we found that when we
space them even further we really were
kind of pushing to get this high level
of efficiency every single time and we
didn't see kind of these wide spectrums
of editing scenarios here and so what
we're actually looking at is in the blue
here you can see that the single guides
when they're kind of close together
versus the green ones and so essentially
what's happening here is when you have
guides that are very close together sort
of the the most active guide RNA will
kind of take over and you'll get most of
the editing genotypes from that most
active guide RNA but when you mix these
together over over space you can see
those actually cooperating together in
many different kinds of ways it's what's
actually happening here like I mentioned
we're mixing several guides together in
a localized region and so they're
forming this fragment deletion we're
doing this in the early exon and this
drives a very strong knockout phenotype
and so sometimes you can have some of
these guide RNAs actually don't work for
effectively on their own but when you
mix the wizz with other guide RNAs that
may be some distance away from those you
can see that they act in this kind of
cooperative fashion and what we're
looking at here is the difference
between mixing these guys together in
this kind of multi guide RNA multiplex
format - the the
two of the best single band you can
appreciate that very few on the
left-hand side er actually work better
individually than the winner
combined with with the friends so to
speak and on the right you can see and
it's kind of blow up that you sometimes
get these extreme cases where you have
two rnas that guide arrays it look like
they have virtually no activity but when
you mix them with another guide iron it
you can kind of completely recover that
that that poor that poor phenotype and
so what we think sometimes may be
happening is that sometimes these RNAs
will actually cut inside the cell and
the repair is actually seamless and so
we don't see an end all being formed we
see a cut and a resection essentially
back together very quickly but when you
and you can individually identify this
but when you mix those with another
guide RNA you can see that you form
these trawl pounds but another way of
looking at this data here is the scatter
plot is you can see on the top that when
you mix these guys together they work
just much more effectively together than
they do do on their own
we took a subset of this data just the
60 genes here out of the hundred that
we're interesting and on the left you
can see that there's a wide range of in
dollars that form in these 60 different
individual guide RNAs and when you
multiplex them together you can really
move up that that particular genotype
and but what's important though is we're
just looking at in dulls and if you're
looking the graph on the right this is
the knockout score so again this is the
percentage of in Dalton or non
derivative of 3 or maybe they make a
larger deletion greater than 20 bases
that it's strong enough to cause a gene
knockout and you can see that there's a
wide range in in those same guide RNAs
most of those guide RNAs cannot form a
frameshift but when you mix them with
with other guide RNAs you're much more
likely to generate a dropout which you
can see from there so really mixing the
guides together was giving us a very
strong knockout phenotype
and we decided to understand understand
if we can actually predict how these
patterns were occurring so in the top
and the three boxes you can see the red
lines actually are where we actually had
spaced the guides together and the blue
lines represent where we actually see
the editing and you can see that those
blue lines always fall on one of the red
lines so based on our spacing we're
always getting a drop out and an editing
event that's exactly where we think it
is so this there's not a whole lot of
kind of random cutting that's occurring
here and this really means that this
mechanism at work here that's actually
predictable and this is really powerful
because it means of mixing these guides
together you can actually kind of bias
your editing experience if you're trying
to form a gene knockout towards getting
you know the highest cutting efficiency
that's going to give you a reliable of
genetic outcome in this particular case
of gene knockout and so it turns out
that perhaps the directionality and
target strand of these guides can be
important and this kind of complicates
the design so what we did is a company
has developed an algorithm that actually
design these guide RNAs with kind of the
optimal spacing along with their optimal
predictive efficiency and the least
amount of off-target effects and we've
done this essentially for every gene now
in the human genome so we can actually
predict and synthesize three guide RNAs
that we're confident will give a gene
knockout phenotype at any particular
locus
we started thinking hey we developed
this cool tool that we wanted centrality
to utilize to make these in vitro models
to form strong gene knockouts could we
could we use this tool can we use these
finding that we discovered to
essentially build a better gene knockout
library a good gene knockout strategy
where you can make a library of all of
these knockouts for the whole human
genome
and so we've really tried some utilize
this multiplex guide RNA and what we
learned from these experiments into
leveraging that into building this
arrayed whole human genome CRISPR
knockout library which is I'll talk
about the development of that right now
so just to remind you again we're using
multiple multiple guide RNAs to drive
this fragment deletion genotype that can
give us a strong knockout phenotype and
it turns out that like if you want to
build a library on a raid library for
for generating gene knockouts it's
really important how you actually build
that build these libraries so we decided
to build these in either 96 or 3d form
or plates and essentially what we're
doing is we're mixing three of these
guide RNAs that are that are going to
work together an optimized fashion to
make that fragment deletion into a
single well into each one of these on
these library plates of course leaving
spaces like we do empty for controls and
things like this and so essentially what
we're trying to do in this library is
almost guarantee that in every well
you're going to get a gene knockout so
we're really trying to make it so
researchers don't have to waste their
time and go back and rescreen well that
didn't form the gene knockout and you
know really doing in this rate approach
helps you to actually later if you want
to kind of go back and mix and match
these together why did we decide to
develop an array library well aside from
the fact that we're synthesizing the
single guide RNA is individually mixing
together there are a lot of advantages
to doing a raid library screening
compared to things like pooled library
screening for example whereas the pool
led library screening is very good for
doing large-scale screens I'll argue
that the raid library can be as well if
you have the right automation setup but
essentially using the pooled approach
you really do are limit it by the types
of phenotypes that you can identify
there's definitely bias in
representation in those libraries and
also the the targets that you can hit as
well and more importantly when you work
in that pooled approach you you kind of
have to go back at the end and D
convolute using some kind of bio from
attic school like exactly what targets
that you're that you're that you're
hitting
arrayed library screening obviously
there's no deconvolution you don't have
any representation bias in your screen
and more importantly you can actually
screen virtually a cell type using these
modified single guide RNAs either as an
RMP or a different format and so you can
also screen virtually any phenotype
since it allows you do a lot more than
you can do in these in these pulled
screens there are some drawbacks of
course you know it's a little more
expensive to do this you have to buy the
reagents and you do need to have some
automation setup as well but it's a
really powerful way of doing an arrayed
doing a library screen of gene knockouts
we decided to design this library to try
be a little bit smarter about how we
actually design it so we looked at other
libraries that people were developing
out there for using these CRISPR
knockouts we could see that a lot of
them really underrepresented the number
of genes in a particular protein
families and we're curious why so we
decided to actually go back and use
multiple different sources to identify
all the genes in a particular protein
family or pathway and so really where
we're trying to be a little bit smart
about this and maximize the number of
targets that could be it could be a say
at a particular library that's very
important like I mentioned we've
actually now done by formatic knockout
design for the whole human genome and
also we broke we have broken these down
into different protein functions protein
families I'll also say that you can
actually get these libraries in any kind
of custom format so you can actually get
you can build your own family of genes
for a particular library that's
something that we can offer to some of
the metrics associated with this library
we were able to actually design on this
three multiplied approach for over 90%
of all the genes of the almost 20,000
genes in the human genome that we're
targeting there are some that are no
it's very difficult to design for that's
kind of just part of dealing with
biology and there are some where we had
to kind of relax some of the rules that
we utilize for for picking these guides
like the aunt aria for example which may
not be so important in a large library
screen how do these libraries behave
here's some examples of genotypic
analysis here we were
knocking out this gene mr PL 12 and you
can see here from these these genotypes
this is the ice analysis using Sanger
sequencing and the three different guide
RNA approach that we're getting a very
high knockout score so 84% of all the
cells in these pool of cell have it have
a genotypic knockout at least and so
we're seeing these large deletions - 130
- 129 that's definitely you're going to
cause a gene knockout when it's in an
early exon and again here's what we're
seeing 100% gene knockout this was
actually quite common it may seem
unbelievable but it's very easy
sometimes for us to get almost the
entire cell population have this
fragment deletion genotype and this also
works well sometimes when I showed
earlier you can only use two guides
because I followed available in that
region but you can also get strong
knockouts this way as well and and we
can prove this to ourselves by doing
things like western blotting in order to
prove that we don't have any protein
present in this particular case we're
just looking at three different genes
here where we knocked out cin p the cosy
or the seedy canine where we just did
some proteomic analysis on the back end
using these westerns to prove that we
didn't have any more protein after using
the multi single rat approach to knock
these genes out so how might this
library that we develop be useful in
your research obviously this technique
is very useful to us for generating cell
lines or for doing our own screening as
well but it may be useful to you like I
mentioned kind of the old way of doing
this was using the silencing RNA
approach again that comes with its own
issues mostly that is transient it's not
a real knockout for meltdown so after
you apply these into cell and after some
time the effect goes away so you may not
be seeing it's essentially the complete
picture of what you're trying to look
for and again using these knockouts as I
mentioned earlier can be very useful if
you're trying to discover a function of
a protein or validate an assay or a
particular antibody that you developed
or also doing pathway analysis inside of
your cell and perturbing those
different nodes to understand exactly
the role of particular protein is a
pathway you might be studying and again
using these four functional genomics is
kind of really the power of utilizing
this these gene knockout libraries and
we feel we have a really good approach
here for maximizing these gene knockouts
in these libraries so when you do these
large-scale screens you're not going to
be wasting your time with with having
genes you actually can't knock out in
your screen essentially knock out all of
the genes that you want to target
how can you deliver on these arrays
libraries well these chemically modified
guides can actually be delivered in
different ways like I mentioned they can
be delivered as our MPs directly into
cells that can be a cell line it could
be a primary cell you can also deliver
these guide RNAs alongside caste 9 mRNA
that works also quite well or also in
cell lines that are already expressing
caste 9 so they have constitutive cast
line expression or maybe castling
expression you can turn on or off and
again these can be delivered all of
these formats are MPs just guide RNAs or
with the mRNA I'm using tools like
electroporation nuclear section which
you can do in high-throughput you can
get a 96-well or a 3d for world nuclear
factor instrument or they can also be
delivered using using techniques such as
lack of ketamine and so here we're just
seeing an example of a small library
that we've built where we delivered the
RMPs using nuclear section to primary
human t cells so to be able to do a
screen and primary in primary cells is
actually is actually quite powerful and
something that was quite difficult
before and so here we're seeing that we
can get these very high knockout scores
sometimes they're not always high as
you'd like but in general you're getting
a lot of protein knockout here in the
small the small library of 28 teams and
the viability that we're seeing is also
very high particularly compared to when
we do a mock transfection so really not
losing a lot in terms of cells when
we're combining these guide or days
together to form these drop outs in any
cell and here's some data that we
generated in collaboration with John
from license lab at University of
California at San Francisco UCSF where
they also delivered the RPS into these
primary human dendritic cells using
nucleic section they happen to do
next-generation sequencing analysis and
what they did is they compared using a
single guide on the left of each one of
these charts here in green to mixing the
guides together which is on the far
right of each of these boxes or or also
individually and you can appreciate if
you look in the box for TN T and F here
you can see that mixing the three guides
together gives you a very strong large
deletion
and in the middle one here for the tlr4
we can see that the single guide they
were using that was predicted to work
quite well using the prediction
algorithm actually perform quite poorly
but multiplexing these three guys
together they got a very strong
genotypic knock out by by NGS so
essentially what you're doing with this
approach is kind of hedging your bets
and you're essentially making sure that
you don't miss any genes that you could
potentially be knocking out that maybe
didn't work just using a single guide
approach and you know really getting
these getting these guys to work
together in a small region that's very
important as we've seen that sometimes
if you just kind of randomly pick guys
across the entire gene they could be in
you know they could be ten or twenty x
on the way and they don't they're not
going to work together so they kind of
need to be be in this controlled
environment and again the algorithm we
did we developed is very useful for that
and so this is the quote from a
researcher a postdoc in Johnson license
lab essentially it's exactly what we
were hoping to do when we develop those
libraries to help researchers like Marco
here really utilize this multiplex guide
RNA approach thinking trying to get the
most effective knockout efficiency and
again this is really help to their work
and has improved the sensitivity of
their screens by really enhancing their
ability to detect some of these weak
phenotypes that they could get from
knockouts maybe they weren't seeing
using the previous single guide approach
you can also deliver these guide RNAs
are these are raids libraries into
Kathlyn expressing lines a little hard
to see the data here but what we've done
is we've actually tried to knock out the
track locus in this castle in expressing
HEC 293 cell line using the CRISPR Max
lipe effect amine reagent so we're using
our keys here
I'm sorry we're using single guides here
into the capsule in expressing line and
so what's really important is that when
you use just a guide into a cell line
that expressing the cassoulet you can
actually use a lot less of the guide RNA
so you can literally get hundreds of
screens out of one of these libraries
compared to maybe you know four or five
screens if you're using the RMP approach
and what you really need to take away
from this is that you actually have to
optimize this for every castle
expressing line
that you work with because you you
really don't know what the decathalynn
expressing the level what the level of
that catheline protein is in that cell
so in this particular case we took just
to go back to that slide we took
different ratios of the life effect
amine and the amounts the concentration
of the guy donating we're delivering in
T cells lowers to find kind of the
optimal range for doing that and you can
see here that when you do these
optimization type experiments you get a
wide range of different genotypes and
it's very important to do this every
time you work with a new cell line and
you're doing a screen so you can make
sure that you can really maximize that
that gene knockout and find the
optimized transmission conditions for
your for your cell line and you can see
how these look also in the the ice tool
so you can put these three guide RNAs in
and really understand what are the
contributing genotypes that you see in
these wells to understand that you're
getting a strong knockout genotype and
we also have protocols are available on
our website for helping you optimize
these if you if you're working with with
like perfection type reagents as well
it's really on there were tons of assays
you can do once you want what you've got
your screen optimized and up and running
the amount of arrays the amount of
assets you can do with these arrays
libraries --is is tremendous it's what
you could be looking at things like cell
survival doing single-cell analysis and
maybe doing some kind of phenotypic
readout that's image based or fax or
actually doing a whole well analysis
using some kind of reporter gene or
luciferase for example
that's kind of wrapping up everything
that I've talked about today we've been
able to generate this very effective
methodology for knocking genes out we
developed this because it was very
important for us or the company to
develop these tools so we did enable our
cell engineering platform it's a
technology that we trust in order to
knock genes out very effectively and
we've now actually kind of shifted this
over kind of tech transfer this into
building a library that's raised library
for the whole the whole human genome as
a knock out and then so when you what
you're actually start to see also is
that if you want a knock out individual
gene will actually also start to produce
these kits that actually focus on
individual genes as well not to be a
product you'll see soon from from the
research lab service indigo so thank you
for for watching if you have any
questions that were about any of the
data that was presented during during
this talk please stick around and
emailing your questions and we'll get
back to those those questions to be
email if you have any if you wants more
information on anything we do as a
company can visit our website you can
learn about the synthetic guides we make
what can we use for Rd maybe you're
interested in clinical application the
multiplex knockout libraries again those
are available for the whole human genome
for different protein families we can
make custom libraries we often make
custom libraries here for ourselves and
again I like I mentioned we're building
these gene knockout kids before you can
actually get this take advantage of this
optimized approach to knock out a gene
very quickly or if you're maybe looking
for us to do some CRISPR editing for you
we can actually also made these gene
knockouts in these CRISPR engineered
cell lines for you that's also the
service that we provide as a company so
hopefully you've learned a little bit
about how the thinking and the science
of one behind how we built this library
and how we adopted it these methods from
from utilizing them to knock out genes
and our salt lines that we were
generating into into the into the
library format that you can use for
doing any kind of
functional genomic screening or athlete
so thank you for your time I appreciate
it and I'm happy to take any questions
that you sent along thank you so much